from her home in leester village on the
outskirts of Freetown haisu Duma could
hear the sound of gunshots and see the
inmates of pademba Road Prison Break
Free a week after what the government
describes as an attempted coup duma's
greatest fear is not political
instability but being unable to feed her
husband and six children especially
especially the price of price it is
skyrocketing every day it has become
worse with $150 you cannot feed your
family since president Julius Madavo
came to power the price of rice has
quadrupled and the value of the local
currency has plunged according to the UN
80% of CER leonian cannot afford basic
food em frustration spilled onto the
streets last year with demonstrators
complaining about high prices the
government responded with police firing
live rounds people are suffering in S
cost of living is unacceptable the the
salaries cannot even survive for one
week so it's easy for the soldiers to
believe that if they stage a coup they
would be welcomed president bu who
staged a coup of his own in 1996 was
reelected in a contested presidential
vote in June now he's trying to unite
the population after last week's
Rebellion the latest coup attempt in a
string of military takeovers in West
Africa during an interview with Al jazer
in October president bio said some coup
were a good thing we should collectively
make the effort to understand why this
trend uh has has picked up so quickly
corruption growing inequality and a lack
of trust in aging politicians seen as
out of touch with a young population
struggling to survive for Isa to Dumba
unless there is change the future looks
bleak Nicholas Hawk Al
jazer make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer